the guys are complaining that there is a
zoom happy hour the staff has once they
say Ronny is taking over the zoom happy
hour and they call it no I won't believe
anything what I heard Oh drinks to live
it to his house I didn't say complain
that was someone else yeah it's always
somebody else you never do anything
Ronny what are you saying about the
Hamptons with JD he's mr. Hampton yes
[ __ ] fancy drinks delivered during
happy hour yeah we're gonna Manhattan
it's not fancy drink whatever you can't
make your own [ __ ] drinks big shot
well that's true yes I know how to make
it let's hear from JD what the
accusation is at least and then you can
kind yeah I didn't use the word
complaint I was someone else I actually
almost kind of like Ronnie running a
happy hour I'm like JD I love it I think
it's great but it's the Ronnie hour I
mean Ronnie is the star of the show and
if anyone tries to steal Ronnie's
thunder they get throwing completely
under the Ronnie hurricane okay Chris
enough you're stupid [ __ ] this is just
like being at the happy every you can
run the [ __ ] happy hour you could be
mr. big shot are you really
announcing the end of your participation
in happy hour yes I'm done I'm not there
happy hour is tearing my staff apart yes
I'm the bad guy
you guys who are fans of Ronnie or
haters of Ronnie will be happy to know
I've uncovered tape of bazoom happy hour
for real oh really
here's a montage of Ronnie's [ __ ]
talking people during the happy hour you
can hear how awkward things get towards
the end of the clip and now Ronnie will
not participate the old wizard [ __ ]
brave now no he started it what
a [ __ ] weatherman now look I classify
you [ __ ] idiot
Wow what happened I don't know pounce on
him Ronnie weird turn let's Friday it
won't [ __ ] it be on [ __ ] you seems very
angry at the happy hour it really is an
unhappy hour sorry you guys are gonna
lose Ronnie no more Ronnie Carson for
you [ __ ]
thank you party is over maybe the puppet
will just show up yeah that's a good
idea
that's great